At precisely 9 AM each morning, the muffled
voice of a woman can be heard greeting her
‘comrades’ across the border.
The source – this wall of 48 speakers built
in 1967 – then proceeds to broadcast a series
of pop songs.
The ‘comrades’ she’s referring to are
not Korean, but Chinese.
And the woman, the late Taiwanese pop star
Teresa Teng.
This 3-story propaganda station lies on the
north-western tip of one of Taiwan’s Kinmen
islands – just three miles from the Chinese
mainland and an hour by plane from Taipei.
Kinmen, in other words, lies on the most fraught
edge of an already fraught region.
In fact, not once but twice has it successfully
repelled Chinese invasions – in 1949 and
50.
But while the Korean border has largely remained
frozen in time – a combustible buffer zone
that few dare cross, this one has changed
dramatically.
Today, this is what life looks like in the
sleepy villages of Kinmen – home to about
100,000 people.
On the other side of the narrow channel that
divides them – and visible to the naked
eye – this is the Chinese city of Xiamen
– population: 5 million.
As China’s economic and military strength
has grown, Taiwan has been forced to confront
its vulnerability.
Kinmen would be among the first and easiest
territory to capture – possibly in a matter
of hours.
Simple pragmatism, therefore, has slowly transformed
this frontier from a highly-fortified garrison
to a kind of commercialized museum.
Once home to 100,000 troops, a mere 3,000
remain today.
In their place, 984,000 tourists – most
of them Chinese – arrived in 2019 alone,
spending about $360 million U.S. Dollars,
and then returning by way of a 20-minute ferry.
The broadcast station still plays propaganda,
but at a much lower volume, and only for the
benefit of tourists.
Meanwhile, this tiny patch of land – little
more than a rock – is one of its few active
military bases.
Its usefulness was recently questioned after
it struggled to shoot down a small, consumer
Chinese drone.
Now, make no mistake – an attack on Taiwan’s
main island of Formosa would be no easy feat.
The landscape is mountainous, the 80-mile
journey treacherous, and the weather, frequently
uncooperative.
Still, the extreme vulnerability of Kinmen
is a powerful reminder of Taiwan’s dependence
on the elephant in the room: the United States.
Sponsored by Nebula, the streaming platform
created and owned by creators.
For just $2.50 a month, you can get access
to our entire catalog of early, bonus, and
original videos.
In August 2021, President Biden surprised
everyone when he told ABC, quote, “We made
a sacred commitment…
that if… anyone were to invade… our NATO
allies, we would respond.
Same with Japan, same with South Korea, same
with Taiwan."
At best, some argued, this was evidence of
Biden’s “declining mental acuity”.
At worst, it was intentional, and therefore
irresponsible – even dangerous.
Others celebrated this long-awaited, ‘momentous’
announcement.
But nearly everyone seemed to agree on one
thing: this was a big deal.
Here’s why…
In 1949, the Chinese Nationalist Party, led
by Chiang Kai-shek, lost the Civil War to
the Communists and fled to what we now call
the island of ‘Taiwan’.
Despite this loss, the United States continued
to recognize it as the sole government of
China for the next 30 years.
During that time, the two countries signed
a mutual defense treaty, promising to protect
one another in case of an attack.
American troops were even stationed in Taiwan.
That treaty ended in 1980 after the U.S. switched
recognition to the People’s Republic on
the mainland.
In its place, Congress passed the Taiwan Relations
Act, which obligates Washington to do two
things:
First, sell the island weapons, quote, “sufficient
[to maintain its] self-defense capability”.
And second, “maintain the capacity… to
resist any… force… that would jeopardize
the security, or social or economic system,
of the people on Taiwan”.
In other words, Biden was not strictly correct.
The United States does not have the same “sacred
commitment” to defend Taiwan as it does
with Japan, South Korea, NATO, and others.
It has the option, of course.
But not the obligation.
Still, perhaps he simply misspoke.
As many were quick to point out, it wouldn’t
be the first time.
Then the same thing happened just two months
later.
And again in May.
Each time, the White House issued a statement
saying nothing had really changed.
And each time, they became less and less persuasive.
Finally, in September, Biden went a step further
– clarifying that American troops would
respond.
After four increasingly-specific statements
in a row, no one could write these off with
a straight face as just mistakes.
Politicians, analysts, and journalists announced
the death of America's four-decade-long policy
of refusing to say whether or not it would
defend Taiwan called “Strategic Ambiguity”
established by Jimmy Carter and upheld by
every president since.
But… not so fast.
When Carter signed the Taiwan Relations Act
in 1979, America didn’t promise to defend
Taiwan – that much is true.
Less well remembered is that it also didn’t
support Taiwanese independence.
It didn’t even, believe it or not, oppose
its unification with China.
In fact, it was widely assumed that it eventually
would.
Washington’s attitude was “this is for
you two to figure out.”
The only thing it actually opposed were “unilateral
changes to the status quo”.
In plain English, anything that wasn’t peacefully
agreed to by both sides.
Now, this may ring hollow.
Surely America wasn’t just some neutral,
disinterested third party.
But the ultimate test of whether it’s sincerely
committed to the status quo or just using
it to undermine its Communist adversary is:
Does it only oppose China’s attempts to
change the status quo or does it also oppose
Taiwan’s?
The answer is that whenever Taiwan has even
flirted with the idea of independence, America
has sprung into action.
Far from cheerleading for that outcome, it
moves to prevent it by occasionally intervening
in the country’s democratic politics to
a degree that would make many Americans uncomfortable.
George Bush, for example, criticized Taiwan’s
President for making relatively minor, symbolic
moves toward independence in the early 2000s.
The Bush administration felt this so important
that it defied intense bipartisan outrage
for “taking China’s side”.
What’s truly amazing about the status quo
is how long it’s persisted despite being
no one’s preference.
Unification is one of China’s oldest and
most important political projects.
The people of Taiwan are stuck in diplomatic
limbo – denied the very real benefits of
international representation.
And most Americans would prefer this vibrant
democracy receive the full recognition it
deserves.
But the guiding principle behind American
policy since 1979 is that – deeply unsatisfying
as it is – the status quo is the least bad
alternative.
The way it’s maintained this delicate balance
for 44 years is by creating room for both
China and Taiwan to believe time is on their
side.
The trick is that no individual Chinese or
Taiwanese leader needs to immediately unify
or declare independence, respectively.
They just can’t afford to lose that future
possibility.
On any given day, forcing unification or declaring
independence would be an extremely risky gamble.
Thus, both leaders have an interest in delaying.
Put differently, the two sides of the Strait
do much of the work of preserving peace by
wearing rose-colored glasses, seeing what
they want to see.
Washington’s only job is to paint a picture
abstract enough that each side can simultaneously
interpret it in a favorable, self-interested
way.
What makes this simple task so challenging
is that it’s a continual process.
Whenever America perceives a change in this
balance – either from Taiwan drifting toward
independence, or China gaining in strength
– it steps in to re-establish the equilibrium.
Reagan spelled out a version of this principle
in a 1982 memo, saying “the quantity and
quality of the arms provided [to] Taiwan [should]
be conditioned entirely on the threat posed
by the PRC.”
In other words: the U.S. hasn’t written
Taiwan a blank check to militarize.
It sells exactly what’s required to maintain
a comfortable balance of power – nothing
more, nothing less.
And, in the last decade or so, the balance
has shifted unmistakably in China’s favor.
First, America has successfully stigmatized
independence in Taiwan.
No prominent politician has advocated for
it in years.
And second, not only has the size and strength
of the Chinese military grown, but the party
has taken a more aggressive tone under Xi
Jinping.
Add to that the Russian invasion of Ukraine
and you can see why Biden might feel the need
to act decisively to restore the balance.
So, in the most straightforward sense, what
he said was new and significant.
In the broader context of America’s attempts
to maintain a balance, he was only re-calibrating
a policy unchanged since 1979.
One thing to keep in mind is that “strategic
ambiguity” has never been official U.S.
policy.
This term has always been an unofficial description
of how journalists and academics perceive
U.S. policy.
The Taiwan Relations Act doesn’t state “We
may or may not defend Taiwan”, it just…
doesn’t say anything.
Besides, ambiguity and clarity aren’t binary
options, they’re opposite ends of a spectrum.
The answer to a question on “60 Minutes”
is less credible than a comment made during
an official speech, which is less credible
than a commitment formalized in a treaty.
Ultimately, the question “Would the U.S.
Defend Taiwan?”
can only be answered by the sitting president.
And because the particular location and circumstances
matter, Biden was effectively speculating
out loud about his own anticipated reaction.
Anyone who claims he’s shifted to a policy
of complete clarity is either overlooking
or presuming the answer to difficult questions.
Questions like: how would he respond to an
invasion only of Kinmen?
It and other so-called ‘indefensible’
outlying islands were specifically excluded
from its former defense treaty.
Hypotheticals like these may sound tedious
and trivial, but it’s exactly these red
lines – or their absence – that determine
a commitment’s credibility.
To summarize: Biden has no doubt moved in
the direction of clarity but there remain
plenty of uncertainties.
But… hold on.
More important than what Biden said, how he
meant it, or why, is what effect it has.
We don’t need to assess anyone’s intentions
or debate whether this represents a change
in U.S. policy to determine whether these
actions increased or decreased the likelihood
of conflict.
So self-obsessed is the world of U.S. foreign
policy that it’s easy to forget something
extremely basic: China already assumes it
would defend Taiwan.
Military strategy 101 dictates that the People’s
Liberation Army must expect and prepare for
American intervention.
Anything else would be dangerously reckless.
And, indeed, many of the weapons Beijing has
invested most heavily in are aimed at, in
the words of the Pentagon, “denying third-party
intervention”.
You can probably guess the identity of that
“third-party”.
In other words, it’s very unlikely that
a verbal commitment from Biden would fundamentally
alter Beijing’s calculus.
Whatever it planned to do before, it probably
still plans to do now.
But it’s not so much the content of the
president’s comments that likely worries
China, it’s their tone.
Tellingly, the Chinese Foreign Ministry’s
reaction was to warn against sending the,
quote, “wrong signals to the separatist
forces of Taiwan independence”.
To translate: it was the implication that
concerned China, not so much the words themselves.
Since the very beginning of the two countries’
relationship, China has been deeply suspicious
that America is only using Taiwan as a way
to undermine it.
Armed with this underlying distrust, it’s
extremely sensitive to any indication that
America is abandoning the status quo and moving
in the direction of independence.
Ironically, the last 44 years of peace prove
that all three parties want the same thing.
At least, they’re willing to tolerate the
same thing.
But Biden’s comments inadvertently feed
into Beijing’s suspicions.
Fearing this is the beginning of a trend toward
independence, China tries to credibly demonstrate
its concern by reacting assertively.
The U.S. then interprets these often quite
dangerous moves as a challenge to the peaceful
equilibrium and acts to offset the change,
which again prompts China to react.
It’s this spiral of escalating reactions
that most worries experts.
It’s how both countries could veer into
a conflict that neither one wants.
As Cornell Professor Jessica Chen Weiss has
said, the challenge is figuring out how to
deter China without provoking it into action
or validating its fears.
Fortunately, we’re not stuck between the
choice of either capitulating to China or
needlessly escalating tensions.
For over four decades, America has sold Taiwan
billions of dollars worth of its best weapons
– proving that it can maintain peace without
inciting war.
Remember, the time-tested approach is to ensure
that (a) tomorrow perpetually feels like a
better time to act drastically than today,
and (b) both countries are reassured that
their worst case remains improbable.
One way to accomplish the former is to increase
the cost of an attack by investing in the
right defenses.
Currently, Taiwan is incentivized to buy a
few expensive and flashy things like submarines
and fighter jets.
Purchases like these help boost morale and
project an image of toughness to voters.
But experts consistently argue a more effective
approach would involve a “large number of
little things”.
This strategy, sometimes called a “porcupine”
or “overall” defense concept, could include
laying mines, building anti-ship defenses,
or stockpiling resources in case of a blockade.
None of these actions would cross any of China’s
red lines – the U.S. already sells weapons
– but they would help strengthen Taiwan’s
defenses.
Now, there is another elephant in the room
we should address: Biden’s recent comments
are representative of an unspoken, bipartisan
consensus: that a Chinese invasion is inevitable
– or even imminent.
“If” has slowly become “when” – a
mindset that encourages quick and sometimes
reckless action.
Reality is much more complicated.
Much of the “evidence” supporting this
belief is the result of misunderstandings
or mis-translations of Chinese speeches.
Only China would initiate a war, and therefore,
only by uncovering the specific forces at
play in China can you truly understand the
probability of conflict – which is why I’ve
made this video doing just that.
In it, we take a closer look at all the evidence
for and against a near-term invasion to get
to the bottom of China’s timeline.
It won’t be available on YouTube until August.
But, you can watch it right now on Nebula,
our independent streaming platform where you
can also find my 6-part exclusive series “China,
Actually”.
There, we explore topics like how Chinese
censorship is both more and less pervasive
than we often imagine and why the country
came to dominate the world of the rare earth
metals ubiquitous in modern technology.
Nebula is also home to other fantastic Originals
like RealLifeLore’s Modern Conflicts, explaining
the wars we always hear about but rarely have
time to untangle.
In “Great Cities”, City Beautiful walks
you through how Shanghai built the world’s
largest metro system, along with other wonders
of the modern metropolis.
Nebula is the absolute best place to watch
my videos.
There are no ads, sponsors, algorithms, or
upgrades – just great videos, all the time.
Now, normally, Nebula costs $5 a month.
But you can get it for 50% off – just $2.50
a month – by signing up for a year with
the link on screen or in the description below.
You won’t find a better deal in streaming.